we've seen an enormous boom in the use
of cloud services because I can i order
my processor cycles on-demand and
virtualization is between the core
technology that's underpinned you know
this enormous change in the way in which
we go about doing business actually as a
technology it's quite old first emerged
in the 1970s I would say many of the
original computer companies produced
different computers that had different
operating systems for different purposes
they had one for accountancy and they
had one for scientific computation and
IBM when it started pushing the IBM 360
which was a complete breakthrough in
computer architecture they realized they
were losing businesses from other
sectors because they couldn't run some
of the operating systems that they
wanted so they invented the idea of
running a virtual machine a virtual
computer on top of the physical computer
and realized rapidly that you could
actually run multiple virtual machines
at the same time so it's an old idea
there's been quite a enormous growth
recently in the use of virtual machine
technology then you know cloud computing
infrastructures as well as being able to
desktop in order to run virtualization
on earlier versions of the x86 family or
everyday PC platforms you need some
software let's start with VMware this
came out of a bunch of very smart people
at Stanford who realized how to perform
software emulation of virtual machines
in simplest terms we often have two
different levels of privilege to run
software on computers we run an
operating system and then we run our
applications and the operating system
can use instructions and access memory
and do things that the applications
can't and that's to avoid the
applications either maliciously or
accidentally crashing the machine and of
course the operating system can but it's
presumed a lot more energy goes into
making sure that works and you don't
want every time your application crashes
especially when you're developing it
that it takes out the whole machine and
these are often in all sorts of
different computer processors there's a
hardware mechanism
implements this is sometimes called the
kernel mode or supervisor mode in the
case of the sort of the intel family of
processors it's called ring zero this is
ring three at this point you may ask
where a ring one and two they are
present but they're not commonly used by
most everyday operating systems but just
think of it as the two privileged levels
so we have this picture and say we want
to run multiple virtual machines with
operating systems clearing charges and
being zero in terms of the privileged
mode so what we try to do we'll try to
run an operating system in the usual
context and then we'll run applications
on top of that so how do we do this
because this operating system running up
here in user mode it will try to issue
instructions and access things that will
cause a fault I mean well you know
that's not the application not permitted
to do that and of course the trick is
this tries to do things that are illegal
and what we do is we make sure it comes
into a piece of the operating system has
been pressed there to provide virtual
machine support and whenever it does
something that only an operating system
can it looks at what I was trying to do
and then causes that effect to happen by
emulating the instruction now I on many
processors they are essentially designed
to be easy to be virtualized able so
they have a very simple instruction set
where it's very easy to decode what's
happening the x86 instruction set is not
one of those processors it's rather
gnarly processor in terms of destruction
set it's often quite difficult and
sometimes ambiguous as to what I was
trying to achieve and so it was an
intellectual marvel from people
knowledge to figure this one out one
other slightly given architecture that
worth looking at is the Xen virtual
machine monitor which is an open source
one and very popular it underpins for
example a vast majority of open source
cloud service provision today including
it runs at the core of Amazon's compute
service then took a slightly different
approach which was similar in a sense
but it had a very small hypervisor is it
like a supervisor that better correct so
you know the terminology it's quite old
it comes from operating systems often
used to be called supervisors and then
when someone said we have something
it's you know that can run multiple
supervisors then what shall we call it
hypervisor
was what's the word was coined again we
are talking 1970s here this ran in ring
0 it's a very much smaller piece of code
and there's one privileged domain domain
0 which actually has the operating
system and accesses and all the physical
devices so in a very important function
of an operating system is to access disk
drives and these and Ed interfaces and
graphics cards and now our guest
operating system as we call it the thing
that's being hosted it then traps into
the operating system so it traps across
into domain 0 it's a slightly different
it's not in the operating system it's
actually a thin layer but it achieves
the same effect it emulates what that
process was trying to achieve now of
course the software emulation of this is
the performance is not that great I mean
you're talking about having to execute
what previously was one instruction
could take many thousands of
instructions you're also talking about
what's called a protection switch where
you switch from one domain of protection
to another that has a cost in terms of
just a number of processor cycles so
that's where we were say 10 15 years ago
it didn't take long before Intel
realized maybe they should add
virtualization support and VT technology
as it's referred to was developed and
released into you know it's of nearly
all Intel processors now I have a
virtualization support and so rather
than having to emulate a lot of this in
software rather the software constructs
a series of tables that the hardware can
access and just make the decision about
was trying to be cheap so today what
this means is that we have virtual
machines and running in these virtual
machines we can have lots of different
operating systems that can be the same
operating system they can be variants
they could be
windows they could be Linux may be
different variants of Linux very
importantly for the commercial sector
was the ability to run legacy operating
systems like Windows NT for all of the
new hardware all the fancy new graphics
cards everything
H&N interfaces district all the new bits
of hardware of course Windows NT 4
hasn't had any software updates for a
long time account use them so it has to
use them in a backwards compatibility
mode so actually by running NT 4 inside
a virtual machine you can get you know
the sort of performance advantages of
modern hardware even though that
operating system doesn't support him
I remember NT 4 from say 15 years ago
who's still using NT 4 there'll be a lot
of people want to do more well there's
still people using LS 2 if you go back
pubs and that the fact is probably some
people using NT 3.51 the reason is it's
sort of a terrible secret of the
software industry we refer to unloved
and uncared for a code as dusty Dex
so the phrase dusty DAC it used to refer
to an unloved and uncared for a stack of
punched cards that have gathered dust
and you then no need to rerun this
software quickly a problem if you have
bought software in that's proprietary
the company's gone the bust and no one's
looking after it there's no support and
your business depends on it there's a
fair chunk of a financial services
sector continuing to run very old legacy
codes in fact they're still running some
of them are still running code on
mainframes because they can't move it on
to modern processors they enabled people
to get the performance advantages but
also deal with the fact that hardware
fails over time but there's a lot of
people to migrate on to new hardware
upgrade but also my if this didn't need
much performance and you've got this you
know enormous 64 core process and I hang
the tank in a way you can just give one
processor to that operating system and
you can use the other processors for
other Roblin systems in a multi-core
processor where there are multiple
processing elements all of these
operating systems are actually running
at the same time in one of the sad
truths is that we haven't yet become
very good at writing applications which
are which can truly use a large number
of processors although they use things
called threads they tend to really be
sequential in their behavior
mostly sequential and so they can only
really make use of one or maybe two
processors and of course in cloud
computing I can sell those small virtual
machines
to different customers so not as a
custom in art I can rent a machine of
whatever size I need one core two cores
four cores two gigabytes of memory four
gigabytes and the configuration of that
is all done by software I didn't have to
buy a particular hardware configuration
so if you look at the cloud service
providers today the way in which I can
provision a new server and applied in a
minute is because their provisioning me
a virtual machine and it's all under
software control and they just create
the virtual machine on-demand and find a
spare process or somewhere and run it
and hand me back the details to allow me
to access it
the mathematics as far as we know is
okay so is this a bit like I've got 17
locks on my front door but he's throwing
in the window yeah so you go in the
window or you pull the wall down you can
find other ways in you can always find
other ways it